So the answer, is that it will never return. And
the reason for this is the stopping test for the
while loop is when there are any more pages to
crawl, so we're going to keep doing this as long as
there are pages in tocrawl. So in order to finish,
we need to know that the value of tocrawl eventually
becomes empty and if we look at the test site.
If you follow the walking link, which the crawler will do,
you get to this page that has a link to
crawling that goes back to the index. That will keep
going, and you're going to follow the walking link again, follow
the crawling link again, following the walk, walking link, following the
crawling link back to the index. And this will continue
forever. The crawler will never finish because it will always find
a link to crawl. And the real web is full
of circular links like this. There are lots of pages that
link to each other. There are also pages that link back
to themself. So to avoid this, we need to do something
smarter. We need to make sure that we don't crawl pages
that we've already done. So we're going to have to be a little
more careful about this step. We need to add a test
to see if we already crawled this page. If we did, we
don't do anything. If we didn't already crawl it, well, then,
we need to add it to crawl, add all the links in
that page to tocrawl and keep going.